esta curva que tenemos aquí marcada en
azul es la gráfica de r igual a 1 -
coseno de teta por supuesto estamos en
coordenadas polares en este vídeo
estamos interesados en calcular el área
dentro de esta región te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta bien hagámoslo juntos ya
obtuvimos de manera intuitiva la fórmula
que nos permite calcular el área dentro
de una gráfica polar la cual va a estar
dada por un medio de la integral
definida desde el ángulo theta inicial
hasta el ángulo theta final desde alza
hasta beta de r de teta al cuadrado de
teta así es que básicamente tenemos que
aplicar esto para esta función que
tenemos aquí así es que en este caso el
área va a ser igual a un medio
la integral definida y cuál es nuestra
alfa y cuál es nuestra meta bien estamos
yendo desde que teta es igual a cero
cuando tet es igual a cero esto es 11
igual a cero estamos en este punto y le
damos toda la vuelta hasta que teta es
igual a 2 y radiales esto es 1 - coche 9
2p 12 nuevos pies 11 menos uno es igual
a cero
regresamos a este punto así es que el
integral va desde que te está igual a
cero hasta que teta es igual a dos pi
ahora cuales r de teta al cuadrado
déjame colorear esto r de teta al
cuadrado esto va a ser uno menos coseno
de teta 1 - jose no detecta elevado al
cuadrado y por supuesto aquí tenemos de
teta de teta y ahora tan sólo tenemos
que evaluar esto y nuevamente si te
sientes inspirado trata de calcularlo
por tu cuenta
vamos por ella lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es reescribir la integral esto es
igual a un medio del integral de 0 a 2
pi voy a desarrollar este binomio al
cuadrado es uno menos dos coseno de teta
más coseno cuadrado de teta de teta de
teta y aquí ya sabemos calcular la anti
derivada de 1 la anti derivada de dos
coseno de teta pero lo que no es obvio
es cómo calcular la anti derivada de
coseno cuadrado de teta aquí no se ve
que haya una sustitución que nos ayude
pero afortunadamente tenemos las
identidades trigonométricas sabemos que
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a un
medio de uno más coseno de dos tetas
esto lo aprendiste en tu clase de
trigonometría de no ser así ya lo estás
aprendiendo ahorita y ésta
definitivamente es una de las
identidades trigonométricas más útiles
para encontrar la integral de una gran
variedad de funciones trigonométricas
apliquemos esta identidad y escribamos
esto de aquí como un medio que
multiplica a 1 + coseno de dos teta y
veamos aquí podemos
hagámosla así aquí podríamos si
quisiéramos no vamos a hacerlo así como
está así es que esto es igual a un medio
y aquí ya vamos a calcular las anti
derivadas
entonces es un medio que multiplica a la
anti derivada de uno de teta esto es
teta menos la anti derivada de dos
coseno de teta la cuales dos seno de
teta la derivada de seno de teta es co
seno beteta y si la multiplicamos por
menos 2 obtenemos menos 2 coseno de teta
y luego tenemos déjame distribuir esto
de aquí esto es igual a un medio más un
medio coseno de dos tetas así es que
esto de aquí es esto que tenemos acá
tenemos que calcular la anti derivada de
un medio la anti derivada de un medio
que es este un medio que tenemos aquí es
un medio de teta más un medio de teta y
ahora tenemos que calcular la anti
derivada de un medio coche 92 teta
veamos la derivada de seno de dos teta
es igual a 212 92 teta así es que la
anti derivada de coseno de 2
y aquí podrías usar la sustitución para
calcular esto si así lo deseas o lo
puedes hacer mentalmente la anti herida
de coseno de dos tetas es igual a un
medio de 92 teta que hay que multiplicar
por este un medio que tenemos aquí así
es que aquí tenemos déjame mostrarte que
estoy calculando la anti derivada de
esto que tenemos aquí que es la anti
derivada de esto que tenemos aquí que va
a ser más un cuarto seno de dos tetas y
aquí te invito a que cheques que
efectivamente esta es la anti derivada
pues el cálculo que hicimos te pudo
haber confundido pero es correcto la
derivada de seno de 2 32 kos en 92 teta
multiplicado por un cuarto nos da un
medio jose 92 teta y esto lo vamos a
evaluar en 2 y 0 de entrada algo que
podemos notar es que cuando evaluamos en
0 todos los términos se hacen 0 así es
que la expresión se hace 0 lo cual nos
facilita el cálculo pues sólo tenemos
que calcular un medio por la expresión
evaluada en dos pi así es que esto es
igual a un medio que multiplica
2 p
- seno de dos pies igual a cero así es
que este término se hace cero más un
medio de dos pi que es para más y más un
cuarto de seno de dos por dos pies es
decir seno de cuatro para el cual
también es cero
este término también es cero así es que
ya casi terminamos esto es igual a un
medio de tres pi o tres medios de pi
tres medios de pi la cual es el área de
la región el área dentro de la curva que
por cierto se llama cardio y d